so
everybody
i think
typically
so
mike
down
dude
david
i like
so
all right
oh my gosh
and i have a second
yes
foreign
would just say
okay
alright
you
the select committee to investigate the
january 6th attack
on the united states capitol will be in
order
without objection the chair is
authorized to declare the committee in
recess at any point
pursuant to house deposition authority
regulation 10
the chair announces the committee's
approval to release the deposition
material presented
during this hearing
good afternoon
in our hearings over the previous weeks
the select committee has laid out the
details of a multi-part pressure
campaign
driven by the former president aimed at
overturning the results of the 2020
presidential election
and blocking the transfer of power
we've shown that this effort was based
on a lie
a lie that the election was stolen
tainted by widespread fraud
donald trump's big lie
in the weeks ahead the committee will
hold additional hearings about how
donald trump
summoned a mob of his supporters to
washington
spurred them to march on the capitol and
failed to take meaningful action to
quell the violence as it was unfolding
on january 6th
however
in recent days the select committee has
obtained new information
dealing with what was going on in the
white house on january 6
and in the days prior
specific detailed information about
what the former president and his top
aides were doing and saying
in those critical hours
firsthand details of what transpired in
the office of the white house chief of
staff
just steps from the oval office
as the threats of violence became clear
and indeed violence ultimately descended
on the capitol
in the attack on american democracy
it's an important it's important that
the american people hear that
information immediately
that's why in consultation with the vice
chair
i've recalled the committee for today's
hearing
as you've seen and heard in our earlier
hearings the select committee has
developed a massive body of evidence
thanks to the many hundreds of witnesses
who have voluntarily provided
information relevant to our
investigation
it hasn't always been easy to get that
information
because the same people who drove the
former president's pressure campaign
to overturn the election are now trying
to cover up the truth about january 6.
but thanks to the courage of certain
individuals the truth won't be buried
the american people won't be left in the
dark
our witness today miss cassie hutchinson
has embodied that courage
i won't get into a lot of detail about
miss hutchinson's testimony will show
i'll allow her words to speak for
themselves and i hope everyone at home
will listen very closely
first i recognize our distinguished vice
chair ms cheney of wyoming for any
opening statement she care to offer
thank you very much mr chairman
in our first five hearings the committee
has heard from a significant number of
republicans including former trump
administration justice department
officials trump campaign officials
several members of president trump's
white house staff
prominent conservative judge and several
others
today's witness miss cassidy hutchinson
is another republican and another former
member of president trump's white house
staff
certain of us in the house of
representatives
recall that ms hutchinson once worked
for house republican whip steve scalise
but she is also a familiar face on
capitol hill because she held a
prominent role in the white house
legislative affairs office and later was
the principal aide to president trump's
chief of staff mark meadows
miss hutchinson has spent considerable
time up here on capitol hill
representing the trump administration
and we welcome her back
up until now our hearings have each been
organized to address specific elements
of president trump's plan to overturn
the 2020 election today we are departing
somewhat from that model because ms
hutchinson's testimony touches on
several important and cross-cutting
topics
topics that are relevant to each of our
future hearings
in her role working for the white house
chief of staff
ms hutchinson handled a vast number of
sensitive issues she worked in the west
wing several steps down the hall from
the oval office
ms hutchinson spoke daily with members
of congress with high-ranking officials
in the administration
with senior white house staff including
mr meadows
with white house counsel lawyers and
with mr tony ornato who served as the
white house deputy chief of staff
she also worked on a daily basis with
members of the secret service who were
posted in the white house
in short miss hutchinson was in a
position to know a great deal about the
happenings in the trump white house ms
hutchinson has already sat for four
videotaped interviews with committee
investigators and we thank her very much
for her cooperation and for her courage
we will cover certain but not all
relevant topics within miss hutchinson's
knowledge today
again our future hearings will supply
greater detail putting the testimony
today in a broader and more complete
context
today you will hear ms hutchinson relate
certain first-hand observations of
president trump's conduct on january 6th
you will also hear new information
regarding the actions and statements of
mr trump's senior advisors that day
including his chief of staff mark
meadows and his white house counsel
and we will begin to examine evidence
bearing on what president trump and
members of the white house staff knew
about the prospect for violence on
january 6 even before that violence
began
to best communicate the information the
committee has gathered we will follow
the practice of our recent hearings
playing videotape testimony from miss
hutchinson and others and also posing
questions to miss hutchinson live
mr chairman i yield back
thank you very much our witness today is
miss cassie hutchinson who served in the
trump administration in the white house
office of legislative affairs from 2019
to 2020 and as a special assistant to
the president in the white house chief
of staff's office from march 2020
through january 2021
i will now swear in our witness the
witness will please stand and raise her
right hand
you swear affirm on the penalty of
perjury that the testimony you're about
to give is truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth so help you god
thank you you may be seated
as a record reflect the witness answered
in the affirmative
i now recognize
myself for questions
mrs hutchinson i'd like to start with a
few questions about your background
the
these are some photographs we've
obtained highlighting your career
these show
you with members of congress including
steve
scalise
as well as the white house with leader
kevin mccarthy and jim jordan
others show you with the president
and members of congress aboard air force
one
before you worked in the white house
you worked on capitol hill for
representative steve scalise the
republican whip and senator ted cruz
and then in 2019 you moved to the white
house and served there until the end of
the trump administration
in 2020
when you started at the white house you
served at in the office of legislative
affairs
we understand that you were initially
hired as a staff assistant
but was soon promoted to a position of
greater responsibility
can you explain your role for the
committee
when i moved over to the white house
chief of staff's office with mr meadows
when he became the fourth chief of staff
it's difficult to describe a typical day
i was a special assistant to the
president and an advisor advisor to the
chief of staff
the days depended on what the president
was doing that day and that's kind of
how my portfolio was reflected
i had a lot of outreach with members of
congress senior cabinet cabinet
officials
we would work i would work on policy
issues with relevant internal components
and members on the hill
as well as security protocol
at the white house complex for mr
meadows and the president
and then you were
you received another promotion in march
2020.
at that time you became the principal
aide to the new white house chief of
staff mark meadows is that right that's
correct sir
a typical day look like for you in your
work with mr meadows
it varied with what was going on we
spent a lot of time on the hill i spent
time on the hill independently too as i
was his liaison for capitol hill um
we did a lot of presidential travel
engagements but mostly i was there to
serve what the chief of staff needed and
a lot of times what the chief of staff
needed was a reflection of what the
president's schedule was detailed to do
that day
so is it fair to say that you spoke
regularly in your position both with
members of congress and with senior
members of the trump administration
that's correct that's a fair assessment
sir
and would you say that in your work with
mr meadows you are typically in contact
with him and others in the white house
throughout the day
that's correct sir mr meadows and i were
in contact
almost
pretty much throughout every day
um consistently
although so much of grave importance
happens in the west wing of the white
house
it's a quite a small building
above me
on the screen
you can see a map of the first floor
of the west wing of the white house
on the right
you can see the president's oval office
on the left
the chief of staff's office suite
within the chief of staff's office suite
is the heart of the west wing
was your desk
which was between the vice president's
office this kirschner's office and the
oval office
mrs hutchinson is
this an accurate depiction of where you
were located
it's accurate
it's a lot smaller than it looks
absolutely
uh
ms hutchinson this is a photo that shows
the short distance
between your office and the president's
oval office
and it only takes five to 10 seconds or
so to walk down the hall
from your office to the oval office is
that right that's correct
thank you pursuant to the section 5 c8
of house resolution five zero three the
chair recognizes gentlewoman from
wyoming miss cheney for questions
thank you very much mr chairman
mr chairman we will begin today with an
exchange that first provided ms
hutchinson a tangible sense of the
ongoing planning for the events of
january 6th
on january 2nd four days before the
attack on our capitol president trump's
lead lawyer mr giuliani was meeting with
white house chief of staff mark meadows
and others
ms hutchinson do you remember mr
giuliani meeting with mr meadows on
january 2nd 2021
i do he met with mr meadows in the
evening of january 2nd 2021.
and we understand that you walked mr
giuliani out of the white house that
night
and he talks to you about january 6th
what do you remember him saying
as mr giuliani and i were walking to his
vehicles that evening
he looked at me and said something to
the effect of
cast are you excited for the sixth it's
going to be a great day
i remember looking at him saying rudy
could you explain what's what's
happening on the six
and he had responded something to the
effect of
we're going to the capitol it's going to
be great
president is going to be there he's
going to look powerful he's he's going
to be with the members he's going to be
with the senators talk to the chief
about it talk to the chief about it he
knows about it
and did you go back
then up to the west wing and tell mr
meadows about your conversation with mr
giuliani i did after mr giuliani had
left the campus that evening i went back
up to our office and i found mr meadows
in his office on the couch
he was scrolling through his phone i
remember leaning against the doorway and
saying i said an interesting
conversation is rudy mark
sounds like we're going to go to the
capitol
he didn't look up from his phone and
said something to the effect of
there's a lot going on cass
but i don't know
things might get real real bad on
january 6.
ms hutchinson mr meadows is engaged in
litigation with the committee to try to
avoid testifying here
um what what was your rea action when he
said to you things might get real real
bad
in the days before january 2nd
i was apprehensive about the six i had
heard general plans for a rally
i had heard tentative movements to
potentially go to the capitol
but
when hearing rudy's take on january 6
and then marx responds
that was the first that evening was the
first moment
that i remember feeling
scared
and
nervous for what could happen on january
6
and
i had a deeper concern for what was
happening
with the planning aspects of it
thank you miss edgeson today we're going
to be focusing primarily on the events
of january 5th
and 6th at the white house uh but to
begin and to frame the discussion i want
to uh talk about a conversation that you
had with mr john ratcliffe the director
of national intelligence and uh you had
this conversation in december of 2020
mr ratcliffe was nominated by president
trump
to oversee u.s intelligence our u.s
intelligence community
and before his appointment mr ratcliffe
was a republican member of congress
as you will see on this clip director
ratcliffe's comments in december of 2020
were prescient
my understanding was mr
director radcliffe
didn't want much to do
with the post-election period
dr radcliffe felt that
it wasn't something that the white house
should be pursuing
it felt it was dangerous for the
president's legacy
he
had expressed me that he was concerned
that it could spiral out of control
and
potentially
be dangerous
either and
for our democracy or
the way that things were going for the
sex
when you say
it wasn't something that would have
should be pursued what's
trying
to fight the results of the election
finding missing ballots
pressuring
filing lawsuits in certain states
where there didn't seem to be
significant evidence
and reaching out to state legislatures
about
that so pretty much the way that the
white house is handling the
post-election period he felt that
there could be
dangerous repercussions
in terms of precedent set for elections
for our democracy
for the six was hoping that we would
concede
so ms hutchinson uh now we're going to
turn to certain information that was
available before january 4th
and what the trump administration and
the president knew about the potential
for violence before january 6.
on the screen you will see an email
received by acting deputy attorney
general donahue on january 4th from the
national security division of the
department of justice
mr donahue testified in our hearings
last week
the email identifies apparent planning
by those coming to washington on january
6 to quote occupy federal buildings and
discussions of quote invading the
capitol building here's what mr donohue
said to us
and we knew that if you have
tens of thousands of very ups obsessed
people showing up in washington dc that
there was potential
the u.s secret service was looking
at similar information and watching the
planned demonstrations
in fact their intelligence division sent
several emails to white house personnel
like deputy chief of staff tony ornato
and the head of the president's
protective detail robert engel
including certain materials listing
events like those on the screen
the white house continued to receive
updates about planned demonstrations
including information regarding the
proud boys organizing and planning to
attend events on january 6th
although ms hutchinson has no detailed
knowledge of any planning involving the
proud boys for january 6th she did note
this
i recall
hearing
the word oath keeper and hearing the
word proud boys
closer to the planning of the january 6
rally when mr giuliani would be around
on january 3rd the capitol police issued
a special event assessment
in that document the capitol police
noted that the proud boys and other
groups planned to be in washington d.c
on january 6th
and indicated that quote unlike previous
post-election protests the targets of
the pro-trump supporters are not
necessarily the counter-protesters
as they were previously but rather
congress itself is the target on the
sixth
of course we all know now that the proud
boys showed up on january 6th
marched from the washington monument to
the capitol that day and led the riotous
mob to invade and occupy our capital
ms hutchinson i want to play you a clip
of one of our meetings
when you described a call on january 4th
that you received from national security
advisor robert o'brien on the same topic
potential violence on january 6th
i received a call
from
robert o'brien the national security
adviser
he had asked if he could speak with mr
meadows about
potential violent words of violence that
he was hearing
that were
potentially going to happen on the hill
on january 6.
i had asked if he had connected with
tony ornato because tony renato had a
conversation with him
with mark about that topic
robert had said i'll talk to tony and
then
um
i don't know if robert ever connected
with mark about
the issue
ms hutchinson can you describe for us mr
ornato's responsibilities as deputy
chief of staff
the deputy chief of staff position at
the white house for operations is
arguably one of the most important
positions that somebody can hold
they're in charge of all security
protocol for the campus and all
presidential protectees primarily the
president and the first family but
anything that requires security for
any individual that has
uh presidential protection so the chief
of staff or the
national security adviser as well as the
vice president's team too
tony would oversee all of that he was
the conduit for security protocol
between white house staff and the united
states secret service
thank you and you also described a brief
meeting between mr ornato and mr meadows
on the potential for violence
the meeting was on january 4th they were
talking about the potential for violence
on january 6th let's listen to a clip of
that testimony
i remember mr ornato had
talked to him about intelligence reports
i remember mr oronato coming in and
saying that we had intel reports saying
that there could potentially be violence
on this on the sixth
you also told us about reports of
violence and weapons that the secret
service were receiving on the night of
january 5th
and throughout the day on january 6th is
that correct that's correct
there are reports that police in
washington dc had arrested several
people with firearms or ammunition
following a separate pro-trump rally in
freedom plaza on the evening of january
5th are those some of the reports that
you recall hearing about
they are
of course the world now knows that the
people who attacked the capital on
january 6th had many different types of
weapons
when a president speaks the secret
service typically requires those
attending to pass through metal
detectors known as magnetometers or mags
for short
the select committee has learned that
people who willingly entered the
enclosed area for president trump's
speech
were screened so they could attend the
rally at the ellipse
they had weapons and other items that
were confiscated pepper spray knives
brass knuckles tasers body armor gas
masks batons blunt weapons
and those were just from the people who
chose to go through the security for the
president's event on the ellipse not the
several thousand members of the crowd
who refused to go through the mags and
watched from the lawn near the
washington monument
the select committee has learned about
reports from outside the magnetometers
and has obtained police radio
transmissions
identifying individuals with firearms
including ar-15s
near the ellipse on the morning of
january 6th let's listen
there's an individual in a tree
maybe a white male about 6 feet tall
ten build brown cowboy boots he's got
blue jeans and a blue jean jacket and
underneath the wooden jacket and we're
complaining both saw at stock with ar-15
you can be with a group of individuals
about five to eight five to uh eight
other individuals
two of the individuals in that group at
the base of the tree near the portal
bodies were wearing green fatigue greens
outdressed thousands of teeth about five
eight five knives any
white males brown cowboy boots they had
glock style pistols in their waistband
87-36 with the message that subject
weapon on his right hip
that he's in the tree
murder one make sure ppd knows they have
an elevated threat in the tree south
side of constitution avenue look with
adult cut on me flag
american flag face mask cowboy boots
weapon on the right right side hip i got
three men walking down the street
fatigue carrying ar-15 copy and fourth
people independent
ar-15s at 14th and independence
as you saw in those emails the first
report that we showed we now know was
sent in the 8 o'clock hour on january
6th
this talked about people in the crowd
wearing ballistic helmets and body armor
carrying radio equipment and
military-grade backpacks
the second report we showed you on the
screen was sent by the secret service in
the 11 a.m hour and it addressed reports
of a man with a rifle near the ellipse
miss hutchinson in prior testimony you
described for us a meeting in the white
house around 10 a.m in the morning of
january 6th involving chief of staff
meadows and tony ronado were you in that
meeting
i was let's listen to your testimony
about that meeting and then we'll have
some questions
i think the last time we talked you
mentioned that
some of the weapons that people had at
the rally
flagpoles
oversized
sticks or flag holes bear spray is there
anything else that you recall
hearing about the
people who would gather on their lips
i recall tony and i having a
conversation with mark probably around
10 00 am
10 15 a.m
where i remember
tony mentioning
knives
guns in the form of pistols and rifles
um bear spray body armor spears and
flagpoles
spears were one item flagpoles were one
item and then tony had relayed to me
something to the effect of
and these i think people are
fascinating spheres onto the ends of
flagpoles
ms hutchinson here's a clip of your
testimony regarding mr meadow's response
to learning that the rally attendees
were armed that day
what was mark's reaction mr meadow's
reaction
to
this list of weapons that people had in
the crowd
when tony and i went in to talk to mark
that morning
mark was sitting on his couch and on his
phone which was something typical and i
remember tony just got right into it i
was like sorry i want to let you know
and informed him like
this is how many people we have outside
the mags right now these are the weapons
that we're known to have it's possible
he listed more weapons off that i just
don't recall
um
and gave him a brief but
and concise explanation but also fairly
fairly thorough
and
i remember
distinctly mark not
looking up from his phone
and i remember
tony finishing his explanation
and it taking a few seconds for mark to
say his name was the point where i
almost
said
mark did you hear him
um
and then bark
chimed in i was like
alright anything else still looking down
at his phone
and
tony looked at me and i looked at tony
and he said no sir do you have any
questions
he's like
what are you hearing
and i looked at tony and i was like sir
he just told you about what was
happening down at the rallies and he was
like yeah i know and then he looked up
and said
have you talked to the president and
tony said yes sir he's aware too all
right good
he asked tony if tony had informed the
president yes and tony said yes he had
so ms hutchinson is it your
understanding that mr ornato told the
president about weapons at the rally on
the morning of january 6th that's what
mr renato relayed to me
and here's how you characterize mr
meadow's general response when people
raised concerns about what could happen
on january 6th
so at the time in the days leading up to
the six there were lots of public
reports about how things might go bad
on the sex even the potential for
violence
if i'm hearing you correctly what stands
out to you is that mr meadows did not
share those concerns or at least did not
act on those concerns
did not act on those concerns would be
accurate
but other people raised him to to him
like in this exchange you mentioned this
is tornado aside that's correct
ms hutchinson
we're going to show now an exchange of
texts between you and deputy chief of
staff ornato
and these text messages
were
exchanged while you were at the ellipse
in one text
you write but the crowd looks good from
this vantage point as long as we get the
shot he was effing furious
and the text messages also stressed that
president trump kept mentioning the otr
and off the record movement we're going
to come back and ask you about that in a
minute
but could you tell us first of all who
it is in the text who was furious
the he in that text that i was referring
to was the president
and uh why was he furious miss
hutchinson
he was furious because he wanted the
arena that we had on the ellipse to be
maxed out at capacity for
all attendees
the advanced team had relayed to him
that
the mags were free-flowing
everybody who wanted to come in had
already come in
but he still was angry about the extra
space and wanted more people to come in
and did you go to the rally in the
presidential motorcade
i was there yes
in the motor game and were you backstage
with the president and other members of
his staff and family i was
and you told us ms hutchinson about
particular comments that you heard while
you were in the tent area
when we were in the offstage announce
area tent behind the stage
he was very concerned about the shot
meaning the photograph that we would get
because the rally space wasn't full
um
one of the reasons which i previously
stated was because
he wanted it to be full and for people
to not
feel excluded because they'd come far to
watch him at the rally
um and he felt the mags are at fault for
not letting everybody in but another
leading reason and
likely the primary reason is because he
wanted it full and he was angry at that
we weren't letting people through the
mags with weapons
what the secret service deemed his
weapons and our our weapons
but when we were in the offstage
announced tent
i was part of a conversation
i was in the i was in the vicinity of a
conversation where i overheard the
president say something's the effect of
you know i don't even care that they
have weapons
they're not here to hurt me take the
effing mags away
let my people in they can march the
capital from here let the people in take
the effing mags away
just to be clear miss hutchinson is it
your understanding that the president
wanted to take the mags away and said
that the armed individuals were not
there to hurt him
that's a fair assessment
the issue wasn't with the amount of
space available in the official rally
area
only but instead that people did not
want to have to go through the mags
let's listen to a portion of what you
told us about that
in this particular instance it wasn't
the capacity of our space it was
the mags and the people that didn't want
to come through and that's what tony had
been trying to relate to him that
morning you know it's not the issues
that we encountered on the campaign we
have enough space or
they don't want to come in right now
they they have weapons they don't want
confiscated by the secret service
and they're fine on the mall they can
see you on the mall and they want to
march straight to the capitol
from the mall
the president apparently wanted all
attendees inside the official rally
space and repeatedly said quote they're
not here to hurt me
and and just
to be clear so
um he was told again
in that conversation or was he told
again in that conversation that
people couldn't come through the mags
because they had weapons correct
and um
that people
and his response was to say they can
march to the capitol from
from the ellipse something the effective
take that i think mags away they're not
here to hurt me
let them in let my people in they can
march the capitol after the rally's over
they can march from they can march from
the ellipse take the effing mags away
then they can march to the capital
ms hutchinson what we saw when those
clips were playing were photos provided
by the national archives showing the
president in the offstage tent before
his speech on the ellipse you were in
some of those photos as well
and i just want to confirm that that is
when you heard the president say the
people with weapons weren't there to
hurt him and that he wanted the secret
service to remove the magnetometers
that's correct in the photos that you
displayed we were standing towards the
front of the tent with the tvs
really close to where he would walk out
to go onto the stage
these conversations happened
two to three minutes before you took the
stage that morning
let's reflect on that for a moment
president trump was aware that a number
of the individuals in the crowd had
weapons and were wearing body armor
and here's what president trump
instructed the crowd to do
we're going to walk down and i'll be
there with you
we're going to walk down
we're going to walk down
anyone you want but i think right here
we're going gonna walk down to the
capitol
[Applause]
and the crowd as we know did proceed to
the capitol it soon became apparent to
the secret service including the secret
service teams in the crowd
along with white house staff the
security at the capitol would not be
sufficient
i've had
two or three phone conversations with mr
renato when we were at the ellipse
and then i had
four men on
mr meadows detail with me
in between
those individuals and a few other bodies
on the ground just see the surface doing
advance
they were getting notifications through
their radios and mr cordado one
conversation had called me and said make
sure the chief knows that they're
getting closer to the capital it's
um
the other trouble stacking bodies
ms hutchinson when you you said they
were having trouble stacking bodies did
you mean that law enforcement at the
capitol uh needed more people to defend
the capital from the rioters
it was becoming clear to us and to the
secret service that capitol police
officers were getting overrun at the
security barricades outside of the
capitol building
and they were having short they were
short people to defend the building
against the rioters
and uh you mentioned that mr ornato was
conveying this to you because he wanted
you to tell mr meadows
uh so did you did you tell mr meadows uh
that people were getting closer to the
capitol and that capitol police was
having difficulty
after i had the conversation with mr
meadows
mr after i had the conversation with mr
ornato i went to have the discussion
with mr meadows he was in a secure
vehicle at the time making a call
so when i had gone over to the car i
went to open the door to let him know
and he had immediately shut it i don't
know who he was speaking with um
it wasn't something that he regularly
did especially when i would go over to
give him information
so i was a bit taken aback
but i didn't think much of it
and thinking that i was would be able to
have the conversation with him a few
moments later
and were you able to have that
conversation a few moments later
probably about 20 to 25 minutes later
there was another period in between
where he shut the door again um and then
when he finally got out of the vehicle
we had the conversation at that point
there was a backlog of information that
he should have been made aware of
and so you opened the door to the
control car and mr meadows pulled it
shut that's correct and he did that two
times that's correct
and when you
finally were able to give mr meadows the
information um about the violence at the
capitol what was his reaction
he almost had a lack of reaction
i remember him saying
all right
something to the effect of
how much longer
does the president have left in this
speech
again
much of this information about the
potential for violence
was known or learned before the onset of
the violence early enough for president
trump to take steps to prevent it
he could for example have urged the
crowd at the ellipse not to march to the
capitol he could have condemned the
violence immediately once it began
or he could have taken multiple other
steps
but as we will see today and in later
hearings president trump had something
else in mind
one other question at this point miss
hutchinson were you aware of concerns
that white house counsel patsy bologna
or eric hirschman had about the language
president trump used in his lip speech
there were many discussions the morning
of the six about the rhetoric of the
speech that day
in my conversations with mr hirschman he
had relayed that
we would be
foolish to include language that had
been included at the president's request
which
headlines
along
to the effect of
fight for trump we're going to march the
capitol i'll be there with you
fight for me fight for what we're doing
fight for the movement
things about vice president at the time
too
both mr hershman and white house
counsel's office were urging the
speechwriters to not include that
language
for legal concerns and also for the
optics of what it could portray the
president wanting to do that day
and we just heard the president say that
he would be with his supporters as they
marched to the capitol
even though
he did not end up going he certainly
wanted to
um some have questioned whether
president trump genuinely planned to
come here to the capitol on january 6.
in his book mark meadows falsely wrote
that after president trump gave his
speech on january 6 he told mr meadows
that he was quote speeding med speaking
metaphorically about the walk to the
capitol
as you will see donald trump was not
speaking metaphorically
as we heard earlier rudy giuliani told
miss hutchinson that mr trump plans to
travel to the capitol on january 6th
i want to pause for just a moment
to ask you ms hutchinson to explain some
of the terminology you will hear today
we've heard you use two different terms
to describe plans for the president's
movement
the capitol or anywhere else one of
those is a scheduled movement and
another one is otr could you describe
for us what each of those mean
a scheduled presidential movement is on
his official schedule
it's notified to the press and to a wide
range of staff that will be traveling
with him it's known to the public known
to the secret service and they're able
to coordinate the movement days in
advance
an off-the-record movement is confined
to the knowledge of a very very small
group of advisors and staff
typically a very small group of staff
would travel with him
mostly that are just included in the
national security package
you can pull an off to off the record
movement together in
less than an hour
it's a way to kind of circumvent
having
to release it to the press if that's the
goal of it or
to not have to have as many security
parameters put in place ahead of time to
make the movement happen
thank you and let's turn back now to the
president's plans to travel to the
capitol on january 6.
we know that white house counsel pat
sipoloni was concerned about the legal
implications of such a trip and he
agreed with the secret service that it
shouldn't happen
ms hutchinson did you have any
conversations with pat sipoloni about
his concerns about the president going
to the capitol on january 6th
on january 3rd mr sipoloni had
approached me knowing that mark had
raised
the prospect of going up to the capitol
on january 6.
mr sipoloni and i had a brief private
conversation where
he said to me
we need to make sure that this doesn't
happen
this would be
a legally a terrible idea for us
we have serious legal concerns if we go
up to the capitol that day
and he then urged me
to continue relaying that to mr meadows
because
it's my understanding that
mr sipoloni
thought that mr meadows was indeed
pushing this along with the president
and we understand miss hutchinson that
you also spoke to mr sipoloni on the
morning of the sixth as you were about
to go to the rally on the ellipse
and mr sippiloni said something to you
like make sure the movement to the
capital does not happen is that correct
that's correct
i saw mr sipoloni right before i walked
out onto west exec that morning
and
mr cipolloni said something to the
effect of
please make sure we don't go up to the
capitol cassidy keep in touch with me
we're going to get charged with every
crime imaginable if we make that
movement happen
and do you remember which crimes mr
sipolini was concerned with
in the days leading up to the six we had
conversations about potentially
obstructing justice or
defrauding the electoral account
let's hear uh about some of those
concerns that you mentioned earlier in
one of your interviews with us
having a private conversation with pat
late in the afternoon of the third or
the fourth
um
that pat was concerned it would look
like we were
obstructing justice
or obstructing the electoral college
count and i apologize for probably not
being
very
firm with my legal terms here but
um
that it would look like we were
obstructing what was happening on
capitol hill and
he was also worried that it would look
like we were inciting a riot
or encouraging a riot to erupt on the
capitol at the capitol
in fact in the days before january 6 and
on january 6 itself president trump
expressed to multiple white house aides
that he wanted to go to the capitol
after his speech
here's what various white house aides
have told the committee about the
president's desire to go to the capitol
did the president tell you this that he
wanted to speak at the capitol correct
yes
during the meeting in the dining room
did the the idea of the president
um proceeding or walking to the capitol
on the six after his speech come up
walking to the capitol no
driving to the capitol
it came up okay how did it come up and
what was discussed
you brought it up you said i want to go
down to the capitol
what about him marching to the capitol
on the sixth um
yes
tell us about that
so
this is kind of a general thing i mean
to get into the specifics of it i
i was aware of the
desire of the president
to potentially
uh
march to the
or or accompany
the
um rally attendees to the capitol
when did you first hear about this idea
of the president accompanying rally
attendees to the capitol on the 6th well
this was at the six this was during the
after he finished his remarks
when the president said that he would be
going to the capitol during his speech
on the ellipse the secret service
scrambled to find a way for him to go
we know this from witnesses
and the secret service
also from messages among staff on the
president's national security council
the nsc staff were monitoring the
situation in real time and you can see
how the situation evolved in the
following chat log that the committee
has obtained
as you can see
nsc staff believed that mogul
the president was quote going to the
capitol
and quote they are finding the best
route now
from these chats we also know the staff
learned of the attack on the capitol in
real time
when president trump left the ellipse
stage at 110 the staff knew
that rioters had invaded the inaugural
stage and capitol police
were calling for all available officers
to respond
when republican leader kevin mccarthy
heard the president say he was going to
the capitol
he called you miss hutchinson
isn't that right
that's correct
and in this text message
you told tony ornato quote mccarthy just
called me too
and do you guys think you're coming to
my office
tell us about the call that day with
leader mccarthy during the president's
speech on the ellipse
i was still in the tent behind the stage
and when you're behind the stage
you can't really hear what's going on
in front of you
so when mr mccarthy called me with this
information
i answered the call and he sounded
rushed but also
frustrated and angry at me and i was
confused because i didn't know what the
president had just said
um
he then explained
the president just said he's marching to
the capitol you told me this whole week
you aren't coming up here why would you
lie to me
i said i'm i'm not lying i wasn't lying
to you sir i
we're not going to the capitol and he
said well
he just said it on stage cassie figure
it out
don't come up here
i said i'll i'll
i'll run the traps on this knot i'll
shoot you a text i can assure you we're
not coming up to the capitol we've
already made that decision he pressed a
little bit more
believing me but i think frustrated that
the president had said that
and we ended the phone conversation
after that
i called mr oronato to reconfirm that we
weren't going to the capitol
and
which was also in our text messages
i sent mr mccarthy another text
telling him
the affirmative that we were not going
up to the capitol and he didn't respond
after that
and we understand ms hutchinson that the
plans for the president to come to the
capitol
um had included discussions at some
point about
what the president would do
when he came up to the capitol on
january 6th
let's look at a clip
of one of your interviews discussing
that issue with the committee when you
were talking about a scheduled movement
did um
anyone say what the president wanted to
do when he got here
no
not that i can specifically remember i
remember
i remember hearing a few different ideas
discussed with
between
mark and scott perry marco rudy giuliani
i don't know
which
conversations were elevated to the
president i don't know
what he personally wanted to do when he
went up to the capitol that day
um
you know i know that
there were discussions about him having
another speech outside of the capitol
before going in i know that there is a
conversation about him going into the
house chamber at one point
as we've all just heard in the days
leading up to january 6th
on the day of the speech both before and
during
and after the rally speech president
trump
was pushing his staff to arrange for him
to come up here to the capitol during
the electoral vote count
let's turn now to what happened in the
president's vehicle
when the secret service told him he
would not be going to the capitol
after his speech
first here is the president's motorcade
leaving the ellipse after his speech on
january 6.
ms hutchinson
when you returned to the white house in
the motorcade after the president's
speech where did you go
when i returned to the white house i
walked upstairs towards the chief of
staff's office and i noticed mr renato
lingering outside of the office once we
had made eye contact he quickly waved me
to go into his office which was just
across the hall from mine
when i went in he shut the door i
noticed bobby angle who's the head of mr
trump's security detail sitting in a
chair
looking somewhat discombobulated a
little lost
um
i looked at tony and he had said
did you i think hear what happened in
the beast
he said
no tony i just got back
what happened
tony proceeded to tell me that
when the president got in the beast he
was under the impression from mr meadows
that the off the record movement to the
capitol was still possible and likely to
happen but that bobby had more
information
so once the president had gotten into
the vehicle with bobby
he thought that they were going up to
the capitol and when bobby had relayed
to him
we're not we don't have the assets to do
it it's not secure
we're going back to the west wing
the president had
very strong very angry response to that
um
tony described him as being irate
the president said something to the
effect of
i'm the effing president take me up to
the capitol now
which bobby responded sir
we have to go back to the west wing
the president
reached up towards the front of the
vehicle to grab at the steering wheel
mr engel grabbed his arm
said sir you need to take your hand off
the steering wheel
we're going back to the west wing we're
not going to the capitol
mr trump then used his free hand to
lunge towards bobby angle and mr when mr
ronato had recounted this story to me he
had motioned towards his clavicles
and was mr engel
in the room as mr ornato told you this
story he was
did mr engel
correct or disagree with any part of the
story from mr ornato mr engel did not
correct or disagree with any part of the
story
did mr engel or mr ornato ever after
that tell you that what mr ornato had
just said was untrue
neither mr ornato nor mr engel told me
ever that it was untrue
and despite this altercation this
physical altercation
during the ride back to the white house
president trump
still demanded to go to the capitol
here's what kaylee mcinanny the white
house press secretary at the time wrote
in her personal notes and told the
committee about president trump's desire
to go to the capitol
after returning to the white house
when you wrote potus wanted to walk to
the capitol
was that based solely on what the
president said during his speech or
anything that he or anybody else said
afterwards
so to the best of my recollection i
believe when we got back to the white
house he said he wanted to physically
walk
with the marchers and according to my
notes he then said uh
you'd be fine with just writing the
beats but so that's my recollection he
wanted to be
a part of the march in some fashion
okay and just for the record the beast
refers to the presidential limousine
yes
president trump did not go to the
capitol that day
we understand that he blamed mark
meadows for that
so prior to leaving the rally site
when he got off the stage
and everybody was making the movement
back to the motorcade i had overheard mr
meadows say to him then as i had prior
to mr trump taking the stage that
morning
that he was still working on
getting an off the record movement to
the capitol so mr trump took the stage
he was under the impression by mr
meadows that
it was still possible so when he got off
the stage
i had related to mr meadows that i had
another conversation with tony the
movement was still not possible
mr meadow said okay and then as they
proceeded to go to the motorcade um
and
mr meadows had reiterated we're gonna
work on sir talk to bobby bobby has more
information
mark got into his vehicle to my
understanding trump got into the beast
and
after we'd all arrived back at the white
house
later in the day
it had been relayed to me by a mark that
the president wasn't happy that bobby
didn't pull it off for him and that mark
didn't work hard enough to get the
movement on the books
the physical altercation that ms
hutchinson described in the presidential
vehicle was not the first time that the
president
had become very angry about issues
relating to the election
on december 1 2020 attorney general barr
said in an interview that the department
of justice had not not found evidence of
widespread election fraud sufficient to
change the outcome of the election
ms hutchinson how did the president
react to hearing that news
around the time that i understand
the ap article went live
i remember hearing noise coming from
down the hallway so i poked my head out
of the office i saw the valet walking
towards our office he had said
get the chief down to the dining room
the president wants him
so mark went down to the dining room
came back to the office a few minutes
later
after mark had returned i left the
office and went down to the dining room
and i noticed that the door was propped
open and the valet was inside the dining
room changing the tablecloth off of the
dining room table
he motioned for me to come in
and then pointed towards the front of
the room near the fireplace mantle and
the tv where
i first noticed there was ketchup
dripping down the wall
and there's a shattered porcelain plate
on the floor
the valet had articulated that the
president
was
extremely angry at
the attorney general's ap
interview and had thrown his lunch
against the wall
um
which was causing them to have to clean
up so i grabbed a towel and started
wiping the catch up off the wall to help
the valet out
um
and he said something to the effect of
he's really ticked off about this
i would stay clear of him
for right now he's really really tipped
off about this right now
and miss hutchinson
was this the only instance that you are
aware of where the president
threw dishes
it's not
and are there other instances in the
dining room that you recall where he
expressed his anger
there were there were several times
throughout my tenure with the chief of
staff that i was aware
of him either throwing dishes or
flipping the tablecloth
um
to let all the contents of the table go
onto the floor and
likely breaker
go everywhere
and miss hutchinson attorney general
barr
described to the committee the
president's
angry reaction when he finally met with
president trump
let's listen
and uh i said look i i
know that you're dissatisfied with me
and i'm glad to offer my resignation and
he pounded the table very hard everyone
sort of jumped and he said accept it
mr chairman i reserve
gentlewoman reserves the chair requests
those in the hearing room to remain
seated
until the capitol police have escorted
our witness from the room
pursuant to the order of the committee
of today the chair declares the
committee in recess for a period of
approximately 10 minutes
[Applause]
first one
not mechanometers the fact that he knew
that they weren't dangerous
uh we don't even know where roger stone
is involved in all this
the fact that he was trying to get to
the capitol to basically lead them into
the capital
uh
you know tells you that this president
had insurrection on his mind was trying
to interfere with
congress's duty to you know certify the
election and uh you know the question is
what happens next and where's merrick
garland all this so i'm gonna go take a
break thank you
mr biggs could come under oath and uh
deny it and then we could see who's uh
who's more willing to tell the truth
she's going to go under oath mr big
seems to be the coward right now by not
going under oath thank you
okay
so
feet
uh
i think
first
that's what happened
thank you
much
so
mike
thank you
okay
so
committed will be in order
she are recognized as a gentlewoman from
wyoming vice chair cheney
thank you mr chairman
before we turn to what ms hutchinson saw
and heard in the white house during the
violent attack on the capitol on january
6.
let's discuss certain communications
white house chief of staff mark meadows
had on january 5th
president trump's associate
roger stone attended rallies during the
afternoon and the evening of january 5th
in washington dc
on january 5th and 6th
mr stone was photographed with multiple
members of the oath keepers who were
allegedly serving as his security detail
as we now know
multiple members of that organization
have been charged with or pled guilty to
crimes associated with january 6th
mr stone has invoked his fifth amendment
privilege against self-incrimination
before this committee
general michael flynn has also taken the
fifth before this committee
mr stone previously had been convicted
of other federal crimes
unrelated to january 6.
general flynn had pleaded guilty to a
felony charge also predating and
unrelated to january 6.
president trump pardoned general flynn
just weeks after the presidential
election
and in july of 2020 he commuted the
sentence roger stone was to serve
the night before january 6th president
trump instructed his chief of staff mark
meadows to contact both roger stone and
michael flynn
regarding what would play out the next
day
ms hutchinson is it your understanding
that president trump asked mark meadows
to speak with roger stone and general
flynn on january 5th
that's correct that is my understanding
and ms hutchinson is it your
understanding that mr meadows called mr
stone on the fifth
i'm under the impression that mr meadows
did complete both a call to
mr stone and general flynn the evening
of the fifth
and do you know what they talked about
that evening ms hutchinson i'm not sure
is it your understanding that mr
giuliani mr eastman and others had set
up what has been called quote a war room
at the willard hotel on the night of the
fifth
i was aware of that the night of the
fifth
and do you know if mr meadows ever
intended to go to the willard hotel on
the night of the fifth
mr meadows had a conversation with me
where he wanted me to work with secret
service on a movement from the white
house to the bullard hotel so he could
attend the meeting or meetings with mr
giuliani and his associates in the war
room
and
what was your view as to whether or not
mr meadows should go to the willard that
night
i had made it clear to mr meadows that
i didn't believe it was a smart idea for
him to go to the lord hotel that night
i wasn't sure everything that was going
on at the willard hotel although i knew
enough about what mr giuliani and his
associates were pushing during this
period
i didn't think that it was something
appropriate for the white house chief of
staff to attend or to consider
involvement in
i made that clear to mr meadows
throughout the afternoon he mentioned a
few more times going up
to the willard hotel that evening
and then eventually dropped the subject
the night of the fifth and said that he
would dial in instead
so general flynn has
appeared before this committee
and when he appeared before our
committee he took the fifth
let's briefly view a clip
of general mike flynn taking the fifth
amendment
uh general flynn do you believe the
violence on january 6 was
justified yes
all right
could you repeat the question please
yes general flynn do you believe the
violence on january 6 was justified
is that
connected to clarification is that a
moral question
i'm asking
both
i said i i said
do you believe the violence on january 6
was justified morally
take the
you believe the violence on january 6
was justified legally
general flynn do you believe in the
peaceful transition of power in the
united states of america
let's move on now to january 6th and the
conduct of donald trump and mark meadows
during the attack on the capitol
as hutchinson i'd like now for us to
listen to a description
your description of what transpired in
the west wing during the attack
for context in this clip you describe
the time frame starting at about 2 pm
so i remember
mark being alone in his office for
uh quite some time and you know
i know we've spoken about ben williamson
going in at one point and i don't
personally remember ben going and i
don't doubt that he had gone in um
but i remember him being alone in his
office for most of the afternoon around
two o'clock to 205
around two o'clock to 205
you know we were watching the tv and i
could see that the riders were getting
closer and closer to the capitol
mark still hadn't popped out of his
office or said anything about it so
that's when i went into his office i saw
that he was sitting on his couch
on a cell phone
same as the morning where he was just
kind of scrolling and typing um
i said
hey are you watching the tv chief
because tv was small
you can see it but i didn't know if he
was really paying attention
watching the tv chief he's like
yeah
the writers are getting really close
have you talked to the president he said
no he wants to be alone right now
still looking at his phone
so i started to get frustrated because
i sort of felt like i was watching a
this is not a great comparison but a bad
car accident that was about to happen
where
you can't stop it but
you want to be able to do something
and i just remember i remember thinking
in that moment
mark needs to snap out of this and i
don't know how to snap him out of this
but he he needs to care
and i just remember i blurted out i said
mark do you know where jim's at right
now
and he looked up at me at that point
said jim i said
marcus he was on the floor a little
while ago giving a floor speech did you
listen he said yeah it was real good did
you like it and i said yeah
do you know where he's at right now
he said no i haven't heard from him
you might want to check in with him mark
and i remember pointing at the tv and
the writers are getting close
they might get in
and he looked at me and said
something to the effect of
all right i'll give him a call
not long after the rioters broke into
the capitol you described what happened
with white house counsel pat sipoloni
no more than a minute a minute and a
half later i see pastor bologna
barreling down the hallway towards our
office
and
rushed right in looked at me
said is mark in his office and i said
yes
he just looked at me and started shaking
his head and went over open
marks off the store
stood there with the door propped open
and said something to the mark is still
sitting on his phone i remember like
glancing and he's still sitting on his
phone
and i remember pat saying to him
something to the effect of the writers
have gotten to the capital mark we need
to go down and see the president now
and mark looked up at it and said he
doesn't want to do anything bad
and pat said something to the effect of
and very
clearly
had
said this to mark something to the
effect of
mark something needs to be done or
people are going to die and the blood's
going to be on your effing hands this is
getting out of control i'm going down
there and at that point mark stood up
from his couch both of his phones in his
hand he had his glasses on still
he walked out with pat
he put both of his phones on my desk
and said let me know if jim calls
and they walked out and went down to the
dining room
a few minutes later representative
jordan called back
a couple minutes later so likely around
between 2 15
2 25 i know the tweet went out at 2 24 i
don't remember if i was
there when the tweet went out or if it
happened right afterwards but
jim had called i answered the phone
said one second he
knew it was i guess he knew and i
introduced myself but i i don't remember
if he called my cell phone or if he had
called one of marx
um but i answered the phones in one
second mark somehow i'm going to go hand
the phones and he said okay
so i went down i asked the valet if
mark was in the dining room
valley said yes i opened the door to the
dining room
briefly stepped in
to get mark's attention
showed him the phone like flipped the
phone his way so he could see it said
jim jordan
he had stepped where i was standing
there holding the door open
took the phone talking to jim with the
door still propped open so i took a few
steps back so i probably was
two feet from mark he was standing in
the doorway going to the oval office
dining room
they had a brief conversation and
in the crossfires you know i heard
briefly like what they were talking
about but in the background i had heard
conversations in the oval dining room at
that point
talking about the hang mike pence chance
that clip ended ms hutchinson with you
recalling that you heard the president
mr meadows and the white house council
discussing the hang mike pence chance
and then you described for us what
happened next
it wasn't until
mark hung up the phone
handed it back to me i went back to my
desk
a couple minutes later
him and pat came back possibly eric
hershman too i'm pretty sure eric
hershman was there
but i'm i'm confident it was pat that
was there
um
i remember pat saying something to the
effect of mark we need to do something
more
they're literally calling
for the vice president to be effing hung
and mark had responded something to the
effect of
you heard him pat he thinks mike
deserves it he doesn't think they're
doing anything wrong
to which pat said something
this is nothing crazy
we need to be doing something more
briefly stepped into
mark's office and when mark had said
something but markup said something to
be effective he doesn't think they're
doing anything wrong
knowing what i had heard
briefly in the dining room
coupled with pat discussing the hang my
pen's chance
in the lobby of our office and then
mark's response i understood there
to be the riders in the capital that
were
chanting
for the vice president to be hung
let me pause here on this point as
rioters chanted hang mike pence
the president of the united states
donald trump
said that quote mike deserves it
and that those rioters were not doing
anything wrong
this is a sentiment that he has
expressed at other times as well in an
interview
with abc news correspondent jonathan
carl
president trump was asked
about the supporters chanting hang mike
pence last year
instead of condemning them the former
president defended them
because
it's common sense
it's common sense
that
you're supposed to protect how can you
if you know a vote is fraudulent
right how can you pass on a fraudulent
vote
to congress
president trump's view that the rioters
were not doing anything wrong
and that quote mike deserved it
helps us to understand why the president
did not ask the rioters to leave the
capitol for multiple hours
in fact he put this tweet out at 2 24
p.m
ms hutchinson do you recall
seeing this tweet in which the president
said the vice president did not have the
courage to do what needed to be done
i do miss hutchinson what was your
reaction when you saw this tweet
as a staffer that worked
to always represent the
administration to the best of my ability
and to showcase the good things that he
had done for the country
i remember feeling
frustrated
disappointed and
really it felt personal i it was really
sad
as an american
i was disgusted
it was
unpatriotic it was
un-american we were watching the capitol
building get defaced over a lie
and it was something that was really
hard in that moment to digest knowing
what i'd been hearing
down the hall
in the conversations that were happening
seeing that tweet come up and
knowing what was happening on the
hill and it's something that i
it's still i still struggle to work
through
the emotions of that
miss edges and we have also spoken to
multiple other white house staff about
their reaction to donald trump's 224
tweet
condemning mike pence for not having the
courage
to refuse to count electoral votes an
act that would have been illegal
matthew pottinger a former marine
intelligence officer who served in the
white house for four years including
including as deputy national security
adviser was in the vicinity of the oval
office at various points throughout the
day
when he saw that tweet he immediately
decided to resign his position
let's watch him describe his reaction to
the president's tweet
one of my staff brought me a printout
of a
tweet
by the president
and the tweet
said something to the fact that
mike pence the vice president didn't
have the courage
um
to do what he what should have been done
um i uh
i read that tweet
uh and uh made a decision
at that moment to resign
uh that's where i knew that i was
leaving that day once i read that tweet
ultimately
members of the white house staff sarah
matthews cabinet members secretary chao
and secretary devos resigned as well
here is secretary devos's resignation
letter
as you can see in resigning on january 6
secretary devos said to the president
there's no mistaking the impact your
rhetoric had on the situation and it is
the inflection point for me
let's also look at secretary chao's
resignation statement
when secretary chau resigned she spoke
of the january sixth attack
and she said quote as i am sure is the
case with many of you
this has deeply troubled me in a way i
simply cannot set aside
miss hutchinson in our prior interviews
we've asked you about what the
president's advisors were urging him to
do during the attack
you've described roughly three different
camps of thought inside the white house
that day can you tell us about those
there's a group of individuals that were
strongly urging him to take immediate
and swift action
i would classify the white house
counsel's office mr hirschman miss
ivanka trump
in that category of
really
working to get him to take action and
pleading with him to take action
there was a more neutral group
where
advisors were trying to toe the line
knowing that mr trump didn't necessarily
want to take immediate action
and condemn the riots
but knowing something needed to be done
and then there was the last group which
was deflect and blame
let's blame antifa these aren't our
people
it's my understanding that
mr meadows was in
the deflect and blame category but he
did end up taking a more neutral route
knowing that there were several advisers
in
the president's circle urging him to
take
more action
um
which i think was reflected in the
rhetoric released later that day in the
videos
you told us that the white house
counsel's office was in the camp
encouraging the president
to tell the writers to stop the attack
and to leave the capitol let's listen
white house counsel's office wanted
there to be a strong statement out to
condemn the rioters i'm confident in
that
now let's look at just one example of
what some senior advisors to the
president were urging ms hutchinson
could you look at the exhibit that we're
showing on the screen
now
have you seen this note before
that's a note that i wrote at the
direction of the chief of staff on
january 6 likely around three o'clock
and it's written on the chief of staff
note card but that's your handwriting ms
hutchinson that's my handwriting
and why did you write this note
the chief of staff was in a meeting with
eric
potentially mr philbin and they had
rushed out of the office fairly quickly
market handed me the note card with one
of his pens
and started dictating a statement for
the president to potentially put out
and
no i'm sorry go ahead that's okay uh
there are two phrases on there one
illegal and then one without proper
authority
the illegal phrase was the one that mr
meadows had dictated to me
mr hershman had chimed in and said also
put without legal authority
there should have been a slash between
the two phrases it was an or if the
president had opted to put one of those
statements
out evidently he didn't later that
afternoon mark came back from the oval
dining room and put the palm card on my
desk
with illegally crossed out
but said we didn't need to take further
action on that statement
so um to your knowledge this statement
was never issued it was to my knowledge
it was never issued
and ms hutchinson did you understand
that ivanka trump
wanted her father to send people home
that's my understanding yes let's play a
clip of you addressing that issue
i remember her saying
at various points no
she wants
him she wanted her dad to send them home
she wanted her dad to
tell them to go home peacefully and she
wanted to include
language that he necessarily wasn't on
board with at the time
you will hear more about this at our
later hearings we have evidence of many
others imploring donald trump and mark
meadows to take action
here is some of that evidence text
messages sent to mark meadows during the
attack
this is a text message at 232 from laura
ingram
hey mark the president needs to tell
people in the capitol to go home
in the next message this is hurting all
of us
and then he's destroying his legacy and
playing into every stereotype we lose
all credibility against the blm antifa
crowd if things go south
the president's son don jr also urgently
contacted mark meadows
at 253 he wrote he's got to condemn this
[ __ ] asap the capital police tweet is
not enough
as you will see these are just two of
the numerous examples of trump
supporters and allies urging the
president to tell his supporters to
leave the capitol
it would not have been hard for the
president to simply walk down to the
briefing room
a few feet down the hall from the oval
office
as norah o'donnell noted during an
interview with house republican leader
kevin mccarthy
where leader mccarthy said he believed
the attack was unamerican
i want to quickly bring in kevin
mccarthy the house minority leader
um leader mccarthy
do you condemn this violence
i completely condemn the violence in the
capital what we're currently watching
unfold is un-american
i am i'm disappointed i'm sad this is
not what our country should look like
this is not who we are this is not the
first amendment this has to stop and
this has to stop now
leader mccarthy the president united
states has a briefing room steps from
the oval office it is the cameras are
hot 24 7 as you know why hasn't he
walked down and said that now
i i convey to the president what i think
is best to do and i'm hopeful the
president will do it
republican house member mike gallagher
also
implored the president to call off the
attack
mr president
you have got to stop this you are the
only person who can call this
off
call it off
the election is over
call it off this is bigger than you it's
bigger than any member of congress is
about the united states of america
which is more important than any
politician
call it off
it's over
despite the fact that many people close
to donald trump were urging him to send
people home
he did not do so until later
much later
at 4 17 p.m donald trump finally told
the rioters to go home
and that he loved them
here's a portion of the video president
trump recorded from the white house
we have to have peace
so go home
we love you you're very special
you've seen what happens you see the way
others are treated that are
so bad and so evil
i know how you feel
but go home and go home in peace
but as we will show in even greater
detail in future hearings
donald trump was reluctant to put this
message out and he still could not bring
himself to condemn the attack
ms hutchinson has told us that too
one that he put out at 4 17.
um
i'm sure you've discussed it and just to
elaborate if i hadn't already at that
point
i recall him
being reluctant to film the video on the
six i was not involved in
any of the logistics or the planning for
that video i just remember seeing the
video go out
and feeling a little shocked after it
went out
on the evening of january 6
and the day after the president's family
and his senior staff and others
tried to encourage the president to
condemn the violence and commit to the
peaceful transition of power
at 3 31 pm on january 6th sean hannity
of fox news texted mark meadows
mr hannity said quote can he make a
statement i saw the tweet
ask people to leave the capitol
later that evening mr hannity sent
another text message to mark meadows
this time he shared a link to a tweet
that tweet reported that president
trump's cabinet secretaries were
considering invoking the 25th amendment
to remove president trump from office
as you can see on the screen
the 25th amendment to the constitution
creates a process for the transition of
power if a president is unfit or unable
to serve
25th amendment has never been used to
remove a president but the committee has
learned that after the attack on the u.s
capitol
this was being discussed by members of
president trump's cabinet
as a way of stripping the full power of
the presidency from donald
trump president trump's supporters were
worried
in addition to the tweet that he sent
mark meadows after the attack
sean hannity apparently spoke with
president trump
and warned him about what could happen
we understand that this text message
that sean hannity sent to kaylee mcaney
on january 7th shows what mr hannity
said to the president first
no more stolen election talk
second
impeachment and 25th amendment are real
many people will quit
ms hutchinson you told us that you were
hearing about discussions related to the
25th amendment here's part of what you
said
mr pompeo reached out to have the
conversation with mr meadows in case he
hadn't heard the
discussions amongst cabinet secretaries
from what i understand it was more of a
this is what i'm hearing
i want you to be aware of it but i also
think it's worth putting on your radar
because you are the chief of staff
you're technically the boss of all the
cabinet secretaries and
you know if
conversations progress you should
be ready to take action on this like i'm
concerned for
you and your positioning with this yeah
please ask me if you have any questions
or like i would be helpful with you at
all
inside the white house the president's
advisors including members of his family
wanted him to deliver a speech to the
country
deputy white house counsel pat philbin
prepared the first draft of what would
be the president's remarks on national
healing
delivered by a pre-taped video on
january 7th
when he arrived at the white house on
the 7th mr philbin believed that more
needed to be said
so he sat down and started writing
he shared the draft with pat cipoloni
who also believed the president needed
to say more
mr sipoloni agreed with the content as
did eric hirschman who reviewed the
draft
the committee has learned that the
president did not agree with the
substance as drafted and resisted giving
a speech at all
miss hutchinson do you recall
discussions about the president's speech
on january 7th
i do
let's listen miss hutcheson to what you
told us about that and about the process
of crafting those remarks
uh i learned from a conversation with
mark and
over here in between him and white house
counsel and
eric hershman as well that
trump didn't necessarily think he needed
to do
anything more on the seventh than what
he had
already done
on the
six when he was
convinced to put out a video on the 7th
he i understand that he had
a lot of opinions about what the context
of that announcement were to entail um i
had original drafts of the speech where
there were several lines that didn't
make it in there about
prosecuting the rioters or calling them
violent
he didn't want that in there he wanted
to put him in that he wanted to
potentially pardon them
um
it was just with the increased emphasis
of
his mindset at the time which was
he didn't think they did anything wrong
he the people who did something wrong
that day or the person who did something
wrong that day was mike pence by not
standing with him
but the president's advisers urged him
to give the speech
who convinced him to do
the video on the seven i'm not sure who
convinced him if it was a group of
people that convinced him
who is in the group that you're aware of
that i'm aware of
mark ivanka
jared kushner
um
eric hershman pasaboloni
pat philbin
those are people that i'm aware of do
you know why that group of people
thought it was necessary for him to
release a statement
i believe kelly mcinerney as well
um
from what i understood at the time
and from what the reports were coming in
there's a
large concern of
the 25th amendment potentially being
invoked and
there were concerns about what would
happen in the senate
if it was if the 25th was invoked
so the primary reason that i had heard
other than you know
we did not do enough on the six we need
to get a stronger message out there and
condemn this otherwise this will be your
legacy the secondary reason to that was
think about what might happen in the
final 15 days of your presidency if we
don't
do this there's already talks about
invoking the 25th amendment you need
this as cover
the president ultimately delivered the
remarks
unlike many of his other speeches he did
not ad-lib much he recited them without
significant alteration except one
even then
on january 7th 2021
the day after the attack on the u.s
capitol the president still could not
bring himself to say quote but this
election is now over
one other point about the speech ms
hutchinson did you hear that mr trump at
one point wanted to add language about
pardoning those who took part in the
january 6 riot
i did hear that and i understand that mr
met that mr meadows was encouraging that
language as well
thank you and here's what you told us
previously about that
you said he was instructed not to
include it who was instructing him not
to include language about the pardon in
that january 7th i understood from white
house counsel's office coming to our
office that morning that they didn't
think that it was a good idea to include
that in the speech that being patented
that's correct
and eric hershman
ms hutchinson
did rudy giuliani ever suggest that he
was interested in receiving a
presidential pardon related to january
6th
he did
miss hutchinson
did white house chief of staff mark
meadows ever indicate that he was
interested in receiving a presidential
pardon related to january 6th
mr meadows did seek that pardon yes
ma'am
thank you miss hutchinson mr chairman i
yield back
i want to thank our witness for joining
us today
the members of the select committee may
have additional questions for today's
witness
and we ask that you respond
expeditiously in writing to those
questions
without objections members will be
permitted 10 business days to submit
statements for the record
including opening remarks and additional
questions for the witness
without objection the chair recognized
the vice chair for a closing statement
thank you very much mr chairman
i want to begin by thanking ms
hutchinson for her testimony today we
are all in her debt
our nation is preserved by those who
abide by their oaths to our constitution
our nation is preserved by those who
know the fundamental difference between
right and wrong
and i want all americans to know that
what ms hutchinson has done today is not
easy
the easy course is to hide from the
spotlight to refuse to come forward
to attempt to down play or deny what
happened
that brings me to a different topic
while our committee has seen many
witnesses
including many republicans
testify fully and forthrightly this has
not been true of every witness
and we have received evidence
of one particular practice that raises
significant concern
our committee commonly asks witnesses
connected to mr trump's administration
or campaign
whether they've been contacted by any of
their former colleagues or anyone else
who attempted to influence or impact
their testimony
without identifying any of the
individuals involved let me show you a
couple of samples of answers we received
to this question
first
here's how one witness described phone
calls from people interested in that
witness's testimony
quote what they said to me is as long as
i continue to be a team player they know
i'm on the right team i'm doing the
right thing
i'm protecting who i need to protect
you know i'll continue to stay in good
graces in trump world
and they have reminded me a couple of
times that trump does read transcripts
and just keep that in mind as i proceed
through my interviews with the committee
here's another sample in a different
context this is a call received by one
of our witnesses
quote a person let me know you have your
deposition tomorrow
he wants me to let you know he's
thinking about you
he knows you're loyal
and you're going to do the right thing
when you go in for your deposition
i think most americans know that
attempting to influence witnesses to
testify untruthfully
presents very serious concerns
we will be discussing these issues as a
committee
carefully considering our next steps
mr chairman thank you i yield back
the woman yields back
ms hutchinson
thank you thank you for doing your
patriotic duty and helping the american
people
get a complete understanding of january
6th and its causes
thank you for your courage in testifying
here today
you have the gratitude of this committee
and your country
i know it wasn't easy to sit here today
and answer these questions
but after hearing your testimony in
all his candor in detail
i want to speak directly to the handful
of witnesses
who have been outliers in our
investigation
the small number who have defied us
outright
those whose memories have failed them
again
and again
on the most important details
and to those who fear donald trump
and his enablers
because of this courageous woman and
others like her
your attempt to hide the truth from the
american people will fail
and to that group of witnesses
if you've heard this testimony today
and suddenly you remember things you
couldn't previously recall
or there are some details you'd like to
clarify
or you discovered some
courage you had hidden away somewhere
our doors remain open
the select committee will reconvene in
the weeks ahead
as we continue to lay out our findings
to the american people
the chair requests those in the hearing
room to remain seated
until the capitol police have escorted
the witness and members from the room
without objection
the committed stands are joined
so
uh
so
you